You may notice for some types like e-mail,
there's some basic validation. But, it doesn't really understand.
If you want to do better client side validation though,
HTML-5 supports that too. There's also a pattern attribute on
the input element, that you can use to validate on
the client side. The pattern element takes a regular expression,
as expressed by the java script regex syntax. Regex is
a topic in itself. So, if you're not familiar with
it, you'll have to look it up. For example, let's
presume I want to only allow U.S. numbers with area
code prefixes. So, an 11 digit number. I can put in a regular expression for
this, and now when I try to input a telephone number and then submit, it
pops up an error message that says I have to match the requested format. That
error message, by the way, is the element's
title, so you can customize it too. And
now, I get my custom error message. Normally
of course, I'm not going to want such a
simplistic pattern. I'll probably going to want something more,
like this string which says, I want a 3
digit number possibly preceded by brackets, and then optionally
a space or a period or a dash, and
then another 3 digits, and then the same space
or period or dash, and then another 4 digits.
Now, this gives some options, for how I enter telephone
numbers, but I can just say, and it'll accept that.